Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to HunieCam Studio!
I changed up my hair so that it's flowing like Phoenix Wright , and eventually I'll play a game like Phoenix Wright and then have this hair.
But anyways, so we're making a lot of money now so I'm going to...
pull Jessie off of...
shopping duty. We need to get another girl in here
and SHE'S gonna be the new shopper because
Jessie is now...
Vvvv- has a lot of fans.
for some reason. I don't know where that happened.
But she got a lot of fans so
Shove this up your butt
and then we're gonna get another girl in here.
but then that means we got to recruit another one
*sharp inhale*
Dingis Dangit
Ok.... And we gotta collect more money, more fastly.
And it just changed over so I gotta buy the new ads....
Ahhh!!!!
Aww, I thought I could get them all.
Alright, whatever.
Good enough
Ok, Kyanna. You need to finish up your training.
You need to go shopping for more cigarettes...
You need to earn more mon-
Eleven thousand dollars??!?!
YEEEESSSS!!!
I think I'm doing WAY better than I did in the last one
I'm not sure, it's very hard to say because in the last one I was clicking like a maniac,
but I wasn't capitalizing on like the..
the stressing out of the.. er, the spreading out of the fetishes and whatnot
god.. I-I-I-I'm
worried because I'm getting used to saying that.
And then it's going to become commonplace for me...
And it sounds...so dirty.
It's so diiiiirty
I don't like it
Hm, okay.
So then one more chubby and then
You're too stressed...
You need to get more of these so everyone else stays unstressed...
You got that... um....
Then she's too stressed which means that we got a lot of problems.
So we have- let me see this again...
Okay, we don't have furry ears so that's what we need...
And then you are going into the brink...
You're gonna be tossed in a river and then bathed repeatedly
To wash the sorrow out of your skin.
And then we'll move forward and be happy and fun and free
Okay so now we need-oh shit I need more...
*Unintelligible*
Audrey: Can I be done now?
Mark: No you cannot be done now!
Why are you giving me so much ATTITUDE?!
You're making THOUSANDS and THOUSANDS
of DOLLARS!
So much money...
Oh I gotta get this before we do thaaat
I need to make sure that everybody is maxed out in terms of...
stripage potential.
That's a weird way of putting it.
I shouldn't put it that way.
Alright, so you're doing that- okay so you're done there...
You're now a good
money maker.
You do that, maximum capacity.
So we need to increase the capacity...
Ahhh, Dingus Dammit...
More Money More Money More Money AND THEN...
This. Okay.
And then, hopefully, before the next cycle tomorrow...
We have enouuuugh so that we can have people-
Tiffany: Anything else?
Mark: No, nothin' else for nooooOOWWWW
Audrey: There. Happy?!
NO, I'M NOT HAPPY I NEED MOOOORE.
MY INTERNAL CURSE IS THAT I ALWAYS NEED MORE
I'M NEVER SATISFIED WITH WHAT I HAAAVE
OH GOD
There's a therapy session with Markiplier here
Okay, thank you
Go back in
Thank you
Non-stop "Let's Plays"!
No matter what!
I don't care how raw your...voice...is?
*nervous laughter*
I don't care how tired you are!
You get back on that camera!
You do more "Let's Plays"!
uhhh
Okay everybody hold off on doing the cam show juuuuust yet...
Okay.
HELLO! You're all different!
Who are you people?
I DON'T KNOW WHO YOU ARE!
"Sarah is an unbearable weeaboo who thinks
she's japanese and calls herself "Suki"
she's the worst but she still kinda hot
in that weird way"
"Renee escaped her hometown in moved out west
to fulfill her dream of becoming an
actress. She's work your way up just heard
somewhere" and Brooke, "Brooke is a wife,
mother, and businesswoman who seeks out
attention online from young men because
her boring husbands leaves her drier than a desert"
Well! Isn't that romantic!
Who do we pick?
We don't have anymore HuniePop characters so we gotta pick from
...everybody else apparently
I mean....
Of these three, the stats kinda go for Sarah...
But also....
Oh man, she-her pay rate is way too high
I mean
*unintelligible*
SHE'S GOT THE MOST FANS! And she's got the least pay! So I
am gonna go with that!
Alright!
Sarah: HI HI HI!
Oh God...
What the hell?!
Sarah: KAWAII!
Oh God what have I done?!
Sarah: Konichiwa senpai!
SHUT UP!
Sarah: HI HI HI!
Oh my God, what have I done?!
*groans*
Sarah: Suki on the job!
Okay...
That's good... I guess
*disgusted noise*
...okay so you're gonna get the furry thing...
*Chuckles* the buttplug!
You're gonna get whatever we got!
You get this...
Shove this up you...
Take that.
Wow--You have FIVE THOUSAND fans
Oh my God...
We're waaaay high in the fan metrics.
Okay but this is good!
So yoooou need training though
She's needs a lot of training before she's gonna be able to do what she needs to do
Oh! Okay we're all processed....
That means we got neeeeeewwww promotional items
Which is goooood....
We're getting more money later because we got everyone---
Literally EVERYONE is in  the cam show right now...
Well--not literally everyone...
I am a liar!
That was a lie!
But...
Figuratively, a lot of people are in the cam show right now...
So here Lola's level five so that's goood...
The only thing that I've learned is that it doesn't---
It doesn't retroactively apply so if you do it halfway through, er, doing a cam show...
It won't give you more money, it's unfortunate like that...
All done I think?
Go back in!
Make sure you're done! You're never done until you're dead!
I'M A VERY STRICT OWNER!
Owner? I don't own anyone here. I wanna be very clear about that. I don't
...own anyone....
Hundred percent!
Totally legitimate operation here
don't need to worry about a thing.
Camgirl: I will!
Mark: *mockingly* I will! Okay, have fun!
Okay, promotion...
Ooooh, now we're getting into the HEEEEEAVY items.
YESSSSS, more fans!
Okay, 21,000
fans on day 14 that means we got a
week of, like, exponential growth to make
sure that eeeeveryone gets as many fans as
possible and it doesn't matter that there's
overlapping, it just matters how many days
left to buy fans because there's no way--
you literally cannot get more fans through
photoshoots. You can't do it it's not
going to help you in the long run, it
won't be enough no matter what you do, no
matter what you try. Its not gonna be enough.
Cam Girl: Did I do good?
Mark: *mocking* Did I do good?
I don't know, shut up!
Oooh, my fingers are starting to hurt.
Too much--what they call in the game--
finger blasting.
That's literally the
terminology that they use.
Not what I use!
They call it finger blasting and I have
no idea what that means cos I'm an
innocent little boy and I dont wanna
even know about anything to do with
being a grown up so we're gonna shut up
about it and noone's gonna be none the wiser.
Do I have--No, okay, so you're now my errand girl
so you're always going to be doing these
things but the only problem is she
always needs to be kind of, like, you know,
*noise to imply drug use*
I just realized the absolute magnitude
of the horrible person that I am.
Goddamit, we just have to buy this so that
we can get more money out. It's so stupid.
I have to buy more to get more money, Goddamit.
Okay, this is where things get kinda juggily
like, not--not just you juggle a lot in
this part of the game because you end up
just like spazzing out about putting
people in different places and getting
them in the right spot at the right
times that you don't really have time to
think about anything else pretty much
everything from this point on is just
dedicated towards one task and that
is simply getting more money to get more
fans to get more money to get more
fans
to get more money to get more fans. Right now we're at 35,000 fans we need a
lot more money to get a lot more fans.
Oh, you did so good, I suppose, maybe.
Yes there it is, okay so now I guess you make--you make too much money to be dodging that one
when but as soon as, um, soon as Tiffany's out of there, Tiffany is gonna be back
into the errand girl because that's
what she do. Because that's how we do it.
It's kinda mean. It's just how we do it.
Everyone's cam showing... How proud I am of this moment where everyone's working together.
So much easier when she's coked out of her mind. Uh, it sounds so bad I'm
such an asshole, such a horrible person. Ugh, it's not good.
Gotta get this... That's maxed... She's there. There we go, that's much better. Now I don't have to
worry about so much stuff going on my own. I mean, I still have to worry about
ya know doin--doing my own thing by myself, but eventually it'll all be handled.
Why are you so stressed out?! What did you do?! You need to go into training... You need just a
little bit more... You're done. You're done. You're done... You got it, I'm the man with the plan!
Everyone's good... Okay, so we got that. Okay.. you get this.
up there you are stressed apparently
why're you stressed
really don't need to be stress right now
my click finger my finger blaster my
blasting finger is very tired so I'm
just going to go back to holding god
damned if I don't have time to do
everything else more fans so much money
so much more money yes I do I need to
reevaluate what everybody has so you
have 10,000 9,000 1410 haven't 17,000
you have the most fans and is that
because
yeah ok so apparently I that's way down
so you can get rid of that you don't
need this you can take that out of your butt
apparently, take one of these and yeah ok
then got all those all those are taken
care of will get a lot of money will get
a lot of money
level five rushing which is way
better way way way better bella's stressed out
but now everyone cycling to be stressed
out everyone's gotta go in everyone's
gotta go in I know I know it's all
synced up all synced up we don't need
to worry about is fine what I want to
know is where the male cam man where's
the cam
guys I don't know I'm not one thats to
knowledgeable about the whole cam world
but it has to exist right it must that
must be a thing cam guys is it I don't
know I don't know if you guys know but I
don't want to know if you guys know it
was just keep that to ourselves and calm
everything down a little bit everyone's
coming out of the stress cycle which
means that every is going back and to
make mons lots of mons go back
here in com- plete oh wow ok these are
now getting ludicrously expensive which
means that we're approaching the final
few days you really have four days left
which is good and bad for now we need to
start getting desperate about money
day we cleared out this day that took 3
30 and my hand is cramped up like you
wouldn't believe my fingers are hurting
my fingys my poor fingys but I'm gonna take a
little break in this episode here and
we're gonna continue this in just a
final episode in the final panic drive
to the end of this game which there is
not much longer left you know what
actually screw that there's not much
left long I'm gonna take a little
breather gonna get right back into it
I'm not gonna let a little thing like
broken bones and arthritis get in the
way my victory and my girls, we're gonna make it YEAH.
if there's one thing that I've learned
from playing this game is that these
girls should asked for a raise because
holy crap of all this money is going to
that fairy and none of its going to me
I'm not make it a goddamn sent off of this
so its full rip off for everybody
involved then why the hell is everybody
not asking for more money? they don't even have their little piggy bank as an excuse!
what are we gonna do? we only got three days left!
AH GOD! AH GOD so expensive! there's actually some desperation
tactics involved in the end of the game
because when you send these lovely
ladies into the hotel to search for
money underneath mattresses and they
have run the risk of being bitten by a
radioactive spider and then being
subjected to a horrible STD's (Spider Transmitted Disease according to Markimoo)
that's going to be debilitating them but
it's an end game tactic because you just
send everybody in there Uhh. because what's
the risk if it does happen anyway so
screw them over for the rest of their life for this stuff It's so bad!
lots and lots of muns.. god damn it need more MUUUNEY
god dammit need more MOOOONEY more money money money, yeah! at least i cleared through, oh no
didn't clear trough this..god dammit, okay gotta
get these last two...aw man I'm not gonna
have enough! ah dammit desperation tactics
are gonna have to come in sooner than I
thought. cause I'm not gonna clear-I gotta
clear through this I got a clear through
it.. Ah! i gotta clear through it
through it, I want to clear through it NOO AHH!
dammit not enough, ah i didn't clear through the
list..Dammit (dissapointed Markimoo) three days left
we didn't make it! we didn't have enough money!
We didn't have enough muns! god dammit! god dammit I need to spend so much
money just to be able to pull the money
out to be able to spend more time
clicking on them to make them go faster
in their jobs so in the end the tally
doesn't matter how much money you have
how many-like what specific type of fans you have; it just matters FANS you need FANS
you need a lot of FANS and you need more FANS then you can count! you need as many FANS you can
hold onto desperately then you just go
about your day! having fun... isn't everyone having fun?
I'm about to engage desperation tactics in
the next move that i make it's gonna be
bad it's gonna start to get ugly it's
going to be compromising a lot of morals
time for desperation! you know what that means...
checking under those mattresses extra
hard even in the dangerous places! ok..
desperation involves just repeatedly dropping
them on the sleazy hotel and hoping for the best because what else can you do
Oh! welp! Jesse got.. well there you go! well at least you can still go work there and that's what
matters but I can't keep everyone there.. I only got two days left so I need to keep
Like a-like a distribution of everyone
doing-but I get tons of muns! OK so
this is good..BAM BAM BAM BAM! yes! ok this is better, ok that's
two of the girls down but at least they can
still go do camera stuff! *wink wink* i you want to
protect some of their innocence though
from those horrible spiders! those damn spiders you know! they get everywhere! not
good! ok Audrey NOOO! both of them?! two?!
two?! two?! TWO!  (yes Mark.) god dammit aw, that's not good well least
they'll be stuck camming for a while.
time for the ultimate finger-blasting (ew) possible it's the final
countdown AHH! GEH! EH! (Mark plz) I'm gonna be my record!
I'm gonna beat my record! Oh I'm gonna beat my record! I am going to
beat my record I just got a go HARD! gotta go HARD! AHH! (Mark seriously)
eh, more promo.. Yes! cleared the board! ok we clear the board
that's what I wanted to do that's what I
needed to do all good now i'll actually be
able to get ahead quite a bit for
tomorrow cause tomorrow is the last day
that were gonna be able to buy them, so
tomorrow's the last day of going to be
able to get any sort of fans so we just
need MUNEY we just need MUNEY *editing jump* last day!
coming up we got it, we rollin and we got it
so much MUNS *editing jump* ah! my hand hurts so badly so
badly but it's the final day I gotta go
for it! I gotta go for it! I gotta go for the gold! i gotta go
for the diamond dick again! gonna beat the
record of the diamond dick *constipated markimoo* ok last day so you
gonna pull out all the stops here and
hope for the best... just hope it's not gonna be
the best i know that for a fact. YEP! DEP!
damn got hepatitis that means AHH (Mark plz there's children watching, watch your language)
AHH (Mark plz no) that's the bad one that's-that's the one that
you can do camming and of course it was
the one girl that..*sharp inhale* alright.. ok.. you just do your thing
we gotta do it. I wanna save Nikki though
I don't want Nikki to go get a spider bite! (Mark picking favorites)
that would be no good! oh I know what she
could do! oh i actually do know what she
could do she could go browse and
hopefully there's like a steroid shot
with his steroid shot you actually have
a chance of uhm.. Er not a chance- wow cleared the board! yeah
oh my god that's that's it then! that's
as much as we're gonna get because going
into do photoshoots is not gonna work is
it won't get things like 30 fans of the
drop in the bucket oh man wow I didn't
expect that to work i guess im done then
what the hell that's weird (Three cheers for Mark!)
what? that's weird! we're done then there's-there's no way to get more, what? I get to
save Nikki! yeah (you didn't save your wrist though.) i dont have to subject her to horrible
spiders yeah I mean there's literally
nothing else to do, Huh that's interesting. Facinating!
I guess everyone I just like
it just pile everyone into the
relaxation spa and just give everyone a
day off I mean job well done everyone
just relax there's nothing else to do I
guess I can just let everyone sitting and be
bygones
i guess im gonna go peacefully into the
night! we're just gonna chill! we're just gonna chill;
got enough smokes and drinks us to last the
rest of the night
its cool! we're just hangin' out! I GET TO SPEND TIME WITH GIRLS! (oh god) I GET TO MEET THEM! THEY'RE GONNA TALK TO ME! THEY'RE GONNA SAY HI TO ME! OMG!
YAY! that's a lot of cam-let's plays! that's a lot of thumbnails being made! that's a lot of yoga points gotten... (keep telling yourself that mark..)
any way. don't drink or smoke i won't
tell you how to live your life otherwise (There's your lesson of the day)
and that but whatever. (If your family ever says you never learn anything on youtube show them this.)
most profitable girl was Kyanna! nice.. most expensive girl was Lola that's to be
expected. (I, the caption maker has nothing to actually put here that's interesting, sorry.)
errand girl was Tiffany.. most popular
fetish was fit. most popular girl was
Audrey apparently wow. BALALALA this is gonna take
forever! Mat sensor that. CENSOR
IT Censor that more! censor that more than the
last one! Matt censor that even more! OH MY GOD. MATT! GERGH?! (?? Mark....)
More censorship! coming in from the left, right, up and down! CENSOR CENSOR CENSOR! *editing jump* Nice! Yeah! i did it!
AH GREAT! OH SO COOL! THANK YOU! OH NO PROBLEM! no- i don't- i don't think so. no i don't think i need to do that too because i've done this
enough. uh huh, cool, oh great! have fun
hello how you doing there again still
the only other thing to show you guys
the wardrobe which is the different
things you can get four different
outfits and once you max out now trade
your special bonus picture that's kind
of creepy and I don't know why anyone
would want to see it all so there you
have been given your outfits and no I
don't have a problem I talk to real
girls okay!But that is Hunie Cam Studio I beat it if you can beat my high
score more power to you because I know
there's some people that are crazy out
there in those in New harder difficulty
those set in the game to try for
yourself if you feel like
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how I did in the comments below and if you enjoy this playthrough,  I would love to know your thoughts!
So thanks again and as always, I will see you! In the next videoo! Buh-Bye!!
Subscribe to Mark for more dorkiness (is that even a word..) like this. and this is the Caption creator saying Goodbye!